IT’S LIKE FROM, FROM 100 YEARS
AGO.
>> Jason: AND AMID THE SURGING
CRIME AND MAJOR CITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, THE LEFT CONTINUES
TO WORK TOWARDS DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
A NEW STORY ON FOXNews.com
STATES THAT ASSUME TO BE
RELEASED REPORT WILL SHOW THAT
ALMOST HALF OF POLICE
DEPARTMENTS NATIONWIDE ARE
GETTING THEIR BUDGETS CUT.
IN OTHER NEWS ABOUT YOUR
SECURITY, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS JUST GOTTEN A
BIG WIN.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS DENIED A
REQUEST TO HALT CONSTRUCTION OF
THE BORDER WALL.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION, DHS
ACTING DEPUTY SECRETARY
KEN CUCCINELLI.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO FIRST REACT
TO THE SUPREME COURT CLEARING
THE WAY FOR SOME $2.5 BILLION OF
PENTAGON ALLOCATED FUNDS TO BE
USED FOR THE BORDER WALL.
>> TWO ENTHUSIASTIC THUMBS-UP.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TOLD US AND HE
HAS DIRECTED HIS ADMINISTRATION
TO PRESS AHEAD AGGRESSIVELY BUT
ALWAYS WITHIN THE BOUNDARIES OF
THE LAW, ALWAYS WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE LAW AND THE
SUPREME COURT ACKNOWLEDGED TODAY
AND IS LEFT THE BUILDING OF THE
WALL CONTINUE.
WE PASSED 200 MILES MORE THAN A
MONTH AGO.
WE WILL PASS 300 MILES WELL
BEFORE THE END OF THE SUMMER AND
WE WILL PASS 400 MILES NOT LONG
AFTER THAT.
WE WILL CERTAINLY GET WELL OVER
400 MILES BY THE END OF THE
YEAR.
JUST AS THIS PRESIDENT PROMISED.
SUPREME COURT HAS KEPT US FREE
TO DO IT.
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION
AND THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS
ARE PRESSING AHEAD HARD TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN AND TODAY’S WIN WAS A
BIG ONE TO MAKE SURE WE STAY ON
TRACK FOR THAT GOAL.
>> Jason: IT WILL AND IT WILL
BE MOST HELPFUL, HAVING BEEN ON
THE BORDER IS MUCH AS I HAVE, IT
WILL BE A HUGE HELP TO THE
BORDER PATROL, NO DOUBT ABOUT
IT.
I ALSO WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION
TO THE STORY THAT YOU CAN READ
ABOUT ON FOXNews.com, THIS
IDEA THAT HAVE A POLICE
DEPARTMENT’S ARE GETTING BUDGET
CUTS IN THIS TIME AND AGE RIGHT
NOW.
I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU, IT’S GOING
TO BE DEVASTATING TO THE COUNTRY
AND ITS RESIDENTS.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
PROTECTING THE CITIZENRY.
YOU CAN’T JUST GO AND CUT THEIR
BUDGET AND NOT EXPECT TO HAVE A
CONSEQUENCE.
>> YOU KNOW, THAT’S WHY POLICE
BECOME POLICE OFFICERS.
THEY WANT TO DO GOOD AND PROTECT
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
OF COURSE YOU HAVE THE EVERY SO
OFTEN BAD APPLE BUT THERE’S NO
PROFESSIONALPROFESSION ON EARTH
HAVE THAT.
FOR PURELY POLITICAL REASONS,
YOU HAVE LEFT-WING GOVERNMENTS,
CITY COUNCILS, MAYORS AND SO
FORTHCOMING THESE BUDGETS.
LET’S BE REALLY CLEAR ABOUT
WHO’S HURT THE MOST.
WHERE DO YOU NEED POLICING THE
MOST?
YOU NEEDED THEM MOST OF THE
POOREST COMMUNITIES, THE
COMMUNITIES A BETTER MOST
CRIME-RIDDEN AND THEY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY MINORITY.
THIS PRESIDENT IS UPSET ABOUT
IT.
HE FIGHTS THAT CONTINUOUSLY, AS
YOU KNOW.
HE PASSED CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
IT’S A BALANCE.
HE’S VERY TOUGH, VERY TOUGH ON
CRIME.
HE ALSO KNOWS WE NEED TO GET IT
RIGHT.
HE DIDN’T WANT HIS PREDECESSOR
WOULDN’T DO ON ON THE REFORM SID
AND NOW WE HAVE ALL THESE
LEFT-WING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT
ARE TRYING TO CUT THEIR POLICE
DEPARTMENTS.
WE HAVE SEEN IT IN NEW YORK.
WE ARE SEEING IT ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AND ITS BAD NEWS FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED IT THE
MOST.
>> Jason: IT’S AMAZING TO ME
THAT DEMOCRATS LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT, GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES
AND MORE GOVERNMENT, EXCEPT WHEN
THEN THEY JUST WANT CHAOS AND
THEY ARE OKAY WITH RIOTING
AND DOMESTIC TERRORISM.
THAT’S THE WAY I SEE IT.
THAT’S WHAT I SEE IS GOING ON.
I NEED YOU TO COMMENT.
GIVE US THE LATEST ABOUT
PORTLAND BECAUSE THERE WAS A
TRANSITION BASED ON WHAT THE
GOVERNOR WAS DOING WITH THE
STATE POLICE.
WHERE’S THE LINE?
ONE PRESIDENT TRUMP MIGHT STEP
IN WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD.
IS IT GETTING BETTER AND WILL IT
SOLVE THE PROBLEM?
>> WELL, VIOLENCE WAS DECLINING
THIS WEEK AND THEN LAST NIGHT
THE STATE POLICE DID WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN ASKING THEM TO DO FOR
MONTHS AND THAT IS TO SHOW UP.
THEY DIDN’T SHOW UP.
THEY BEGAN DOING THE POLICING
THAT THE PORTLAND POLICE
WOULDN’T DO AROUND THE
COURTHOUSE ON THE FEDERAL
FACILITIES AND LO AND BEHOLD,
INTO MONTHS, WE HAD OUR FIRST
NIGHT WITHOUT VIOLENCE LAST
NIGHT.
AND THIS IS I TOLD YOU SO MOMENT
REALLY BUT WE HAVE STILL GOT TO
GET THROUGH THE WEEKEND.
WEEKENDS ARE ALWAYS TOUGHER FOR
MAYOR RIOTING AND VIOLENCE
STANDPOINT.
WE WILL SEE HER TONIGHT AND
TOMORROW NIGHT GO.
WE ARE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
PART OF THE REASON WE WERE
POSITIONED TO GO ON THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IS BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUPPORTED US IN
ADVANCING OFFICERS INTO PORTLAND
TO PROTECT THAT COURTHOUSE AND
PROTECT THE FEDERAL FACILITIES
AND FRANKLY I THINK THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WERE JUST
EMBARRASSED THAT WE WERE HOLDING
OUT THE WAY WE WERE AND DOING
OUR JOB AND PERFORMING OUR
MISSION WERE EVERYWHERE ELSE IN
AMERICA, EVEN OTHER CITIES WHERE
THE PRESIDENT IS AT ODDS WITH
THE MAYOR, WE STILL COOPERATED
THE PROFESSIONAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
LEVEL BUT NOT IN PORTLAND.
GOVERNOR BROWN IS CHANGE THAT.
IT WILL GIVE HER THAT CREDIT.
THIS IS A WIN-WIN FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION GOVERNOR BROWN
AND HER STATE POLICE.
IT MAKES PORTLAND LOOK PATHETIC,
MORE PATHETIC.
BE THAT AS IT MAY, THEY DID WHAT
WE ASKED.
TOOK THEM A LONG TIME TO DO IT
BUT AS SOON AS THEY DID IT, IT
STARTED TO WORK.
>> Jason: IT’S AMAZING, JUST
HOW HAVE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
DO THEIR JOB.